[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et tout le monde avait un
avis sur eux pendant près de dix ans
l'équipe de tpm paix était leader des
tokio jusqu'à ce que cyril hanouna
décide d'ouvrir un snack dans le sud
ouest avec l'amour de sa vie
mais quinze ans après que sont devenus
ses acolytes quelle est leur nouvelle
vie loin des flashs
il est où le youki 1 il est où nous
avons pu en rencontrer certains il ya 15
ans ces visages nous accompagner chaque
soir
mais quelle est leur nouvelle vie
mokhtar le célèbre homme de sécu a suivi
la business school of ouarzazate et il
est devenu l'un des plus grands patrons
français ou à quoi sert elle est partie
j'ai décidé de reprendre les choses en
main j'ai racheté la chaîne baptisée b 8
sata cuite et en tant que nouveau boss
de la chaîne prend t'il des nouvelles
des anciens chroniqueurs
non mais j'ai croisé gens me l'a pas
longtemps une rondelle aux escrocs or la
plus grande reconversion a été opéré par
le monsieur chiffres de l'émission
thierry moreau bon bah quand tu es pmp
s'est arrêté j'ai rejoint lci
et puis deux ans plus tard la chaîne est
devenue une chaîne porno ou à se décider
de rester d'ailleurs j'ai gagné une
toque d'or pour mon rôle dans
arrête de pompey pénélope et je tenais
ma dorénavant thierry est plus connu
sous le nom d'acteur x titi l'amoroso et
avez vous gardé contact avec la bande de
tpb
non mais j'ai croisé jean louis il n'ya
pas longtemps on m'a demandé de losail
normal enfin le chouchou des
téléspectateurs jean luc lemoine a
décidé de quitter le monde de la télé
dès l'arrêt de l'émission y occupe
aujourd'hui un poste à responsabilité
dans l'agroalimentaire 8,45 ou un petit
sac à prêter pmp on était tous un peu
nostalgique il ya gilles verdez qui m'a
proposé de monter un spectacle en duo
aspect aujourd'hui gilles hashtag tout
est possible c'était pas une super idée
mais jean-luc lui non plus n'a aucune
nouvelle de la joyeuse bande de tpb
annonce 0 nouvelles voies nouvelles
personnes me rappelle si si il ya là
jean michel qui m'a demandé de l'osé une
fois depuis depuis plus de nouvelles
pour les autres sachez que valérie
bénaïm a décidé de lancer sa propre
marque de couscoussière et jean michel
maire à lancer une association dont
l'adresse s'affiche en bas de votre
écran
bonne soirée à tous sur terre
[Musique]